they'll join the American systems that
they're putting in the same type of
missiles so they'll complement that and
they'll just really really augment the
American sort of platforms and those
were the missiles they'll use and the
UK's um gchq Chief this week warned that
Russia is running out of weapons given
the Allies hollowed out stockpiles is
there a risk that Western allies are
going to run out of weapons to support
Ukraine first no there isn't a risk
because unlike Russia who has already
isolated itself and we saw that
yesterday at the United Nations vote you
know they need a supply chain and large
parts of their supply chain were not in
Russia they came from all over the world
including in Europe and including indeed
in even in Ukraine some of their supply
chain was in Ukraine so we have the
ability to refurbish or indeed
manufacture a new supply chain which is
what we're doing right now and the UK
Danish joint-led international fund is
all about placing orders in a in
manufacturing space to make sure that we
can go on between 23 24 and keep going
on and next week NATO is going to be
holding its annual nuclear deterrent
exercises is that wise given current
tensions with Russia isn't there a risk
that that would just raise the chances
of a misunderstanding especially given
the language that Vladimir Putin is
using about his nuclear Arsenal well
Russia will also be conducting its
annual exercise I think the week after
or just after uh the annual
guys I think that's the key what we
don't want is to do things out of
routine this is a routine exercise and
it's all about readiness you know today
you know the NATO meeting is all about
making sure we are ready for anything I
mean that is the job of this Alliance is
to make sure that the 30 Partners
together are ready for what is thrown at
us and we have to continue work at that
and so exercising is part of that
Readiness including a nuclear attack by
Russia in Ukraine like how would the
NATO respond to that well I'm not going
to speculate I mean the the fundamentals
are NATO is a an alliance of all types
conventional and nuclear powers and and
fundamentally we are here to make sure
our Readiness is for whatever is
serenity
thank you very much